à la mairie on passe ancien chef quoi tu
te particiaption toi on y va c'est parce
qu'il n'ya qu'un pas
[Applaudissements]
ils sont pas fichés holding j'aime
j'aime pas on n'avait pas le taux
d'affaires mais on va parler juste de
pascal le contraire de ce qu'on dit un
du mortard ya x men le commencement est
vrai très gros il pascal le grand frère
j'aime j'aime pas j'aime à agathe agathe
aime bien et ça n'arrivait tous l'agate
maxime
alors on va voir un extrait hier dans
l'émission dont on a rencontré anaïs une
adolescente de saison elle est très
rebelle notamment envers sa mère elle
n'hésite pas à lui dire qu'elle a une
mauvaise haleine par exemple ont regardé
et j vous n'avez pas du tout aimé les
littoraux dire delà du cul tu fout de la
gueule wihr tata me dis bah tu pue de la
gueule c'est le lcq des problèmes
d'estomac
elle pense pouvoir matin avec sa jupe en
ce sens les chevaux de selle donc ça pue
à pau alors hier c'était donc un des
extraits vous aimez vous dites ça parce
que pascal et là vous n'aimez pas
valérie et non mais j'adore parce
qu'elle jouait déjà dit à plusieurs
reprises c'est que mouassa m'empresse en
fait je suis très angoissé quand je le
regarde je me dis ça me gêne donc j'ai
envie de zapper pour pour passer à autre
chose y revenir quand ça sera bien il y
en avait un la table gilles verdez parce
que c'est surtout ça je voulais juste
voir si vous aimez le cinéma garder vos
pancartes
vous n'avez pas du tout aimé l'émission
d'hier vous vouliez même en parler à
pascal bien sûr à ce cas là la france
attend maintenant vos excuses hier soir
c'était une catastrophe
ce n'était pas le grand frère c'était
pascal le grand père il s'est rien passé
ni avait des ralentis interminables et
des plantes vous en permanence au début
vous avez pris le melon série hbo c'est
pas lui qui comme lui qui m'ont plans
ralentis c'est moi j'étais film au
ralenti tu t en arrêt était en arrêt sur
deux fautes depuis depuis longtemps et
elle en dieu que tu en as rome
[Applaudissements]
jaloux ont fêté prétention c'est coiffé
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est toi qui est
mou c'était tellement mauvais ton truc
qu'on aurait dit un mauvais de l'or au
mode entraînement alors on va voir avec
ce n'est pas ce colloque tu l'avais pas
parce que il ya moi je t'ai trouvé drôle
tu t'es moquer d'anaïs qui a une passion
pour les oiseaux c'est court et très
drôle vous avez même poussé la
chansonnette perdu été trouvée drôle
mais s'il vous n'avez pas trouvé
l'épisode bourré d'humour mais bien
pascal quand même non oui oui oui mais
pas du goût des autres chaînes c'est ça
dix de ses fans de ces mecs là
franchement ils sont classe spec là
quand tu vas voir ta piaule des jaseurs
toi tu es une fan oublie moi c'est quoi
il a même été créé en chanson je cite
cette mimi cracra vous assure un
plusieurs sociétés sa patte sur un
accent anglais mi mai
quoi quoi oui mais pourquoi à toulouse
[Applaudissements]
alors nouvelle carrière pour moi je veux
c'est vrai alors qu'ils étaient stars
répondent pourquoi tu cours tu la
trouves étoiles épisodes d'hier dit la
vérité
bon ben on était bien on a une grosse
concurrence comme le foot en vase si
l'on fait cap millions et puis moi on
n'est pas trop mauvais fait quatre ans
de 5 juillet mais ils servent à ça pas
mal ce coup c'est voilà c'est ça passe
c'est un bref voilà on dit la vérité
cependant je ne fais pas ou fait mais ça
passe voilà oui et vous contentez
tournée où vous participé au montage
aussi que c'est un peu ce que la voix on
se calme parce que la voix off là elle
est complètement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
par exemple à voir l'épisode d'hier
l'épisode était mou il a même plus de
sport moi j'adorais quand on tapait sur
la glace quand il est sur vrai oui mais
hier c'est un coup de gueule contre
l'émission de 10 mais oui c'est s était
soporifique quoi alors moi je peux vous
dire un truc pascal me dit la vérité à
moi j'adore l'émission merci mais c'est
vrai que je trouve que ça manquait un
peu de calme et oui je trouve que depuis
que l'émission est arrivée sur ces 8
je ne sais pas si c'est la chaîne qui
fait des conneries avantage c'est très
possible non plus des génies on n'est
pas des génies on va dire on fait
beaucoup de conneries aussi je fais
partie de la chaîne je me mets dedans et
je sais pas je trouve que ça s'est un
petit peu il me disait teasé par rapport
à ce qu'ils avaient avant alors est ce
que c'est une demande de ses huit n'ont
pas du tout pas du tout auparavant ont
cassé des briques ont cassé la glace
monsieur gilles verdez se plaignait
parce qu'on casse est trop de choses
maintenant on est dans la vraie vie
c'est ça la vraie vie c'est ça et
monsieur gil arias ça ne lui plaît pas
mais il ne dit rien qui lui place une
vraie vie c'est pas du tir à la corde et
du mal à bouger vite souhaitons
construire lorsqu'il a regardé
l'émission a gagné deux fois sur le foot
deux fois j'ai remis la regarder tout ça
à faire regardez le me fallait mission
pour vous dire qu'il se fait chier pas
tout je suis fan de pascal il le sait je
trouve que l'émission en tant que tel
après son passage à l'énergie d'où je
pense qu'il faudrait vraiment garder
votre personnage et faire un truc
vraiment différent ayant effectivement
je me suis franchement je me suis un peu
ennuyé n'y avait pas les codes que
j'avais pu retrouver l'allant le
producteur c'est julien voulait
retourner à une pépite comme aux forces
qui a évidemment regardé le créneau mais
faire un truc différent l'aï honnêtement
pour moi ya pas eu de surprise alors le
régime voilà voilà
après pascal mon 3g fabre et la semaine
prochaine si elle doit c'est une fille
ou un garçon une fille a une fille
encore ouais moi je pense que mes fils
sera qui sera différent de celui ci et
là vous allez voir je te dis la vérité
aussi je pense cédé il ya des erreurs
les filles moi moi j'ai c'est vrai que
je trouve que c'est moins gênant avec
des garçons qu'avec des filles pascal
canfin je prends ensuite le prochain ce
sera encore des versions mais mes frères
cette fois ci très bas mais le maire
c'est en tout cas voilà gilles tétanie
ce que tu as à dire tu dis la vérité